[Music]  people are gearing up for Easter this  weekend but here's the problem with the  economy in rough shape many people have  to stick to a tight budget when buying  Easter candy and gifts so here with some  money saving Easter tips once again is  our prop master bill tall bill  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  take a chocolate Santa stick to KitKat  bars on them  boom chocolate bunny here's there with  another tip take a dozen eggs leave them  on your radiator for eight months boom  colored eggs here's another one  [Applause]  take a bottle of scotch and some porn  boom good Friday  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  have sex without a condom  boom egg hunt  [Applause]  take a Jesus figurine stick him on some  Jiffy Pop boom he has risen  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]